[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
inspired by my last countdown video of
the most overpriced things in all of
tech this is the best stuff in tech
right now in terms of bang for the buck
ratio these are the best deals in tech
so if i were you i would check out the
links down below the like button on this
video like asap because these things are
bound to sell out like they do all the
time and to be honest some of them
already are and these are the absolute
best priced you could say underrated but
mostly underpriced deals in technology
number five is the nexus 7 200 quad core
tablet i think that's all that needs to
be said the nexus 7 pretty much takes
the credit for starting the seven inch
tablet movement we mostly only saw
around 10 inch tablets before the nexus
7 came around the nexus 7 came around
and suddenly everyone wants to make a
seven-inch tablet but also the nexus 7
gets credit for starting to race to the
bottom the race to the lowest priced
good tablet you could possibly make asus
and google pretty much nailed it on the
head 200
tiger three quad core and uh that's
pretty much as low as we've gone and
we've seen other competitors totally
fail the kindle fire hd just total
failures for the same price point so the
nexus 7 pretty much nailed it in terms
of cheap tablets we're also bound to see
the next nexus 7 this year i don't know
if it's going to be called the nexus 7
again but we can pretty much count on
seeing something along the lines of a
1080p quad-core tablet from google
that's a 7-inch tablet but for now
in the play store the google's nexus 7
is about as good as it gets so that
takes the number five spot for best
price tech number four is the audio
technica ath m50 headphones now you've
probably already saw this one coming but
if you're new here i have raved about
these headphones before these sound like
300 350 headphones they cost less than
180 pretty much all the time on amazon
again the link is below for that but
basically these are really high quality
studio monitors they're pretty solid
design there's pretty much nothing
fundamentally wrong with the m50s and
you would expect to pay around three
hundred dollars for them but they cost
180 i don't know it's just the way audio
technica built such high quality stuff
into a package like that is beyond me
and i'm really glad that they're still
selling it and it's still one of the
best prelim best selling headphones
products on amazon right now which says
a lot about how good it is and also the
number one review happens to be my video
of it so if you're curious
check it out it's it's pretty much
awesome i've had my pair for close to
three years now and so that can vouch
for the durability of them again i use
them to edit all my videos so i know
that they sound really good i listen to
music on them all the time honestly if
you don't have a pair of over over-ear
headphones something that sort of
isolates the noise and sound around you
i can listen to these on an airplane i
mean you definitely want to check these
out so yeah athm50 is at number four
number three is the canon t3i oh yes
it's easily among the best bang for your
buck dslrs out there it's especially
good for people who are just starting to
get into photography or videography
especially for video because it has that
articulating lcd screen like the canon
60d and the canon t4i in fact i would
venture to say that the t3i is basically
a t4i minus the touchscreen which makes
it incredibly good it sells for a really
good price again i'll have all the links
below but i i started my video
production with a canon t2i and so of
course the t3i is going to get super
awesome video quality just like the t2 i
got
so i i really couldn't recommend
anything more um i know nikon makes some
really similarly priced dslrs i'm not a
big nikon person so i would actually
recommend checking out some other
reviews on the nikon side of things but
the t3i is awesome it's great price it's
basically a t4i without the touchscreen
or you could say a t2i on steroids and i
love it so yeah check that out t3i and
if you're looking on the point-and-shoot
side of things canon makes the powershot
elph
hs
super popular camera especially among
youtubers so check that one out if
you're looking for a more portable
camera uh again very low priced and it's
a great wide-angle lens on it so you can
like vlog with it you can take awesome
pictures with it check it out number two
the nexus 4. this one is probably an
easy decision uh why are these so hard
to get right now because they're sold
out everywhere and not just because
google's trying to manipulate the
numbers and make you think they're sold
out they're actually getting higher
demand than they were expecting and
they're selling like crazy so in the
play store the 8 gigabyte quad core
nexus 4 costs 300
for an unlocked phone that's pretty
impressive considering other snapdragon
s4 pro phones like the droid dna or the
find 5 cost upwards of 500 600
and the note 2 and the iphone 5 will
cost more than 600 dollars unlocked so
if you want to combine this with a
t-mobile unlimited data contract for 30
bucks a month this can be an incredibly
affordable option for those of you who
want an inexpensive smartphone and it's
not just that it's inexpensive it's
actually a good phone so yeah nexus 4.
great price and the number one most
underpriced thing in all of tech right
now you're probably not expecting this
is the klipsch s4i
how the hell are these still 60 as a
background clips has been a pretty solid
maker of audio products for a while now
they make studio monitor headphones and
they make a lot of earbuds and they make
a lot of different accessory products
for your devices but the s4i are earbuds
that have been selling insanely well on
amazon right now they cost less than 60
dollars but they are ridiculously good
they sound good they're durable they
have little controls in line so if you
have an ipod or a smartphone you can use
the controls on those for them they're
just all around full-featured 130 dollar
headphones that are just slashed down
into a 60 price tag somehow i don't know
how they keep selling these i don't know
if they're selling them at a loss or if
they're just that good at manufacturing
if their processes are that streamlined
so props to clips these are by far and
away the best sounding inexpensive
earbuds and there are some of the best
earbuds i've ever used personally i
still use my eclipse s4i when i go out
but i do have a video review coming up
of another pair of earbuds you guys are
going to like but still the clips s4i
are awesome and pretty much anytime
anyone asks me to recommend earbuds i
say clip s4i and they're happy a week
later when they get them so there you go
guys with the top five uh at least in my
book best priced or underpriced things
in all of tech honorable mentions go to
shout outs to storage storage is really
cheap you can get a two terabyte hard
drive for like 100 bucks it's insane so
go out and get one if you don't have one
already backups are really easy the
canon 60d because it just dropped a lot
in price that's a camera that a lot of
big youtubers actually still use and
it's i think somewhere around 700 so
check that out the links to all these
things are below the mac mini because
you can actually suit this thing up to
be a really solid machine i did the
fastest mac mini in the world project if
you click on that it'll open in a new
tab uh it's an annotation obviously but
i'll have the link to that as well below
and you can actually suit this thing up
to like really power through benchmarks
and that ssd and throw as much ram in
there as you can and it's actually a
pretty solid little machine basically a
macbook pro kind of crunched down into a
desktop form factor pretty neat and the
audio technica ath m35s because if you
can't have m50s you just you just get
the m35s they're that cheap so there you
go guys those are the top five deals and
some shout outs in tech right now again
if you want another top five video or if
you have any suggestions for more
definitely leave them in a comment below
and i've also created a playlist of all
the countdowns that i've ever done so if
you check out that link below you'll be
able to go back way back in time and see
all the things my old self recommended
to people like you either way thank you
for watching definitely stay tuned for
the next video and i will talk to you
guys in the next one peace
[Music]
you